- Every week, we put together
a little guide of great stuff
for you to watch, read, see, follow,
do and listen to over the weekend.
First up, somewhere to visit!
If you like natural beauty
and cracking open a cold one,
we've got the perfect thing
for you to do this weekend.
Go to michelobultra.com
and fill out an application
to be their chief exploration officer.
Because the beer, this is serious.
I mean, this is real.
By the way, wait until you hear the story.
You're gonna want to sign up.
The beer brand,
if I didn't have my dream
job, I'd be signing up.
But I'm so lucky.
The beer brand wants to
pay someone to travel
the country's beautiful
national parks and snap pics
and rep their brewskies along the way.
It pays $50,000 for six months of work,
plus gas and expenses.
Transportation obviously,
thank goodness, is provided.
A sweet camper with its
own shower and bathroom.
But the bigger takeaway,
honestly, no matter what,
is I'm a lifelong RV enthusiast.
I've driven around this
great country my entire life.
And they've done this mapped out markings
of all these states and its landmarks.
And I have to tell you,
you've got to check it out,
if for no other reason to get
great suggestions and ideas
of places to hit.
It's really comprehensive.
Okay, I'm a map collector and
I've driven around the country
and I was really impressed with this list.
Next, what to watch.
Time for a movie this weekend.
Opening at our drive-in
movie and here's to watch,
"The Broken Hearts Gallery."
It's a story about a young
woman who turns her heartbreak
into an art installation
for everyone to see.
Wow, take a look.
- [Geraldine] There are broken
people out there like me.
People who need to let go and move on.
- [Woman] Is this the heartbreak thing?
- You're in the right place, welcome.
Are you ready to hand it over?
- It has an odor.
- We're in business, baby.
- It looks great.
And I think it's a really fresh concept
and it stars the sweet and
funny Geraldine Viswanaw,
thun, from "Blockers."
Let me try that again.
Geraldine Viswanathan.
I only practiced that seven times too.
That's what's so maddening about that.
She's from "Blockers"
and "Miracle Workers,"
and she's like all the rage
and it's a really great
romcom treat for the weekend.
Next up, time to hit follow.
A good follow is food52 on Instagram,
num, num, num, num, num, yom, sammy sols.
If you enjoy drooling over fresh
pastas and many other food,
you are going to love this account.
They also post amazing
user-friendly recipes and videos.
You can get so lost in them.
They're eight minutes long.
It's perfect, new chefs
that they recommend.
And their kitchen tools,
I'm telling you, this is the place to shop
if you're an enthusiast.
All right, next.
Download One Second Every Day.
It's an app that takes one
second from all your videos
in your library and cuts
together a little movie
for you out of all of them.
And I fall in love with
this app a little more
every time they send me another
little montage of my life.
It's so beautiful.
And finally, one last thing.
I want to recommend Magnolia Bakery.
Their banana pudding!
(audience clapping)
They have released this recipe
and they are world famous
for this banana pudding.
And people are going bananas!
And they're shipping this
pudding all over the place.
I'm telling ya, it's crazy.
Magnolia was first made famous
when Carrie and Miranda ate
cupcakes from Magnolia Bakery
on that "Sex in the City" episode.
You know, ever since
moving to New York myself,
I've wanted to become a real Manhattanite
(laughing) like Carrie Bradshaw.
I couldn't help but wonder
what would it feel like
to walk just like Carrie
and be in one of her Manolos for a day?
So I did.
(playful jazzy music)
(upbeat music)